and also in the new york times what it
calls the torture of dressing for your
holiday office party they're starting
author jennifer whiner writes you have
to navigate the journey from
professional to party choosing clothes
that signal that you are polished
without being boring attractive without
being provocative and that you're
looking to be promoted not proposition
for women that is never easy it seems
whiner is a contributing opinion writer
for the New York Times and author of the
upcoming novel I like this title missus
everything everything everything she
joins us to discuss holiday party
adequate and a kitten authors how you
pronounce that word and how people
should navigate social gatherings
especially after the rise of the meaty
meat to movement welcome back to you Jen
let me back it's why would be here well
I have to say I groaned a little bit
when I heard you were coming to discuss
this because I thought not you not me
topic I thought in 2018 yes here we are
having this friggin congressman you
don't have in this friggin conversation
that said it seems every year somebody
gets into trouble at the holiday party
every time so I think it's still
necessary for us to have it well I mean
I have to ask first of all like why are
we having holiday parties at all well do
morale okay wouldn't you rather have an
extra hundred dollars in your paycheck
you have to go like put on the Spanx
close it on anyway yeah be social with
that you know the guy with like the
stale coffee breath who's been like kind
of looking at your backside every time
you go to the copier how that is well
we're never know I don't you know it
never looks at my butt jack oh come on
but let me do is we're never given the
option of would you rather have more
money or go the whole holiday party is
here not optional yeah I have to do it
and and it's tricky because like I said
in my article men have a uniform okay
you put on a suit you put on a tie your
dress and if you decide you're
overdressed you take off the tie and
then you're good to go and for women
it's like okay if it says holiday
festive like what does that mean does
that mean like what I wore to work today
plus a necklace like an acute shoe and
then I have to bring that and what if
it's not right and this is such a
throwback though the suggestion that
what I wear is that I'm asking for it I
know that's what's been that has been as
you know that well she dressed that way
therefore she deserves it is a are we
past that and why are we focused more on
behavior rather than on what people are
wearing why don't we just have
conversation of norms
behavior that would people that would be
lovely that would be fantastic
unfortunately as as anyone who's been
like living and breathing and paying
attention knows we're not there yet and
certainly in my industry and publishing
a lot of the guys who got taken down in
in me to situations it was for
off-campus activities it wasn't what
they were doing at the office it was
what they were doing
you know you're out for drinks or you're
at a party and so I do that does not
have any to it but the women were
wearing no and it has to do with their
own poor behave it absolutely does and
we should be policing their behavior
rather than our clothing and I I agree
with that completely what I'm saying
though is that unless it says ugly
sweater party you don't know what to
wear all the time and it's and it's
tricky and I I think you you know you
look in the catalogues and everything's
cute and everything's kind of sexy and
everything's like you know I'm here to
have a good time but that's not what you
want to be that's not the message you
want to be sending at the office in
limiting alcohol consumption oh my god
absolutely yes yes do not do not drink
have a friend have a plan like if that
guy who checks out your boat when you go
to the copier corners you have a friend
who is gonna be like looking out for you
and saying like you know hey Sarah come
on over here you know with me yeah we
can't avoid the creepy guy avoid the
creepy guy what else can you do yeah
what else can you do at an office party
you know I I joke that like
unfortunately if I was telling somebody
what to wear I'd see a body camera at
this point so you find a body camera and
the Christine Blasi Ford Memorial
one-piece bathing suit under the clothes
which is terrible but here we are moving
aside from that there are all kinds of
other reasons that holiday events are
fraught so you walk up to your boss you
want to say just enough but not too much
sure should you just avoid the boss
altogether in cinema no I do want to
talk to the boss you want to show that
you're a team player that you you like
where you work you like what you do you
want more responsibility you want a
promotion you want to raise you know do
you say all that at the party all that
at the party and your side hustle like
you're selling Rodan and fields on the
side definitely bring that up no don't
you so how do you turn it into an
opportunity I
I think you want to be your neck full
your best self okay I think you want to
bring your best self to that party and
you don't necessarily have to be
explicit about like promote me and give
me a raise but just show that you are
the kind of person who deserves
promotion what if your best self is at
home on the couch with your dog do you
pay a penalty if you don't go to the
party yeah you question you have to go
and I have to go I speak as someone
whose best self is currently on the
couch watching The Simpsons with no
spanks why do you have to go because you
wanna you want to show that you're a
team player and you want to show that
you want that job you want to be there
you like these people even if you don't
you know make it good fake it till you
make it you have a good model though you
sort of you make an appearance you say
hi to everybody and you're not the last
person at the party ever the last person
here do your stuff yeah yeah say hi all
right face time okay I'm gonna wear this
all right for my holiday party my
hospital just says I'm just gonna go
take a tour up and down the whole bridge
absolutely and I just say noir has a
very nice-looking frigerator with good
stuff inside